Of course, we did not ignore
the situation around Ukraine. We believe that
many of the provisions of
the peace plan outlined by China are consonant with the Russian
approach and can be taken as the basis
for a peaceful settlement when they
are ready for it in the West and in Kiev. However,
such an approach is
not yet such a readiness on their part.
we observe Great Britain, through the
Deputy Head of the Ministry of Defense of
this country, announced not only the
supply of tanks to Ukraine and shells with
combined uranium
It seems that the West really decided
to fight with Russia to the last, the Ukrainians are
no longer in words but in deeds, but in
this regard I would like to note that if all this
will happen, then
Russia will have to react accordingly,
bearing in mind that the
collective West is already starting to use
weapons with a Lego nuclear component
[applause]